hello and welcome to Lutie session
okay what time control what time control
do we play
um I am not sure if I'm ever getting
games with this but I can try
two plus one
what I usually call in German and a
bullet so
retiree bullet let's say I think it's
actually this is not a bad time control
I think they had some quick games and I
don't I don't get any so okay let's go
for blitz
not so easy my rating is not super high
but but quite high and that sometimes
difficult to get games
z Groot
time hmm yeah I had some they'd to get
him or her on her on a recent session
going for his Indian
it's always a bit dangerous to play if
you like I am I'm not really up-to-date
in with the theory the King's Indian was
my main defense against one deform
in the 1990s and a-one many crucial
games with it
when I made my first I am norms
problem is that I'm not really up to
date at all I know that this is a line
we should f5 I think is a somewhat
recent trend recent means like in the
last 10 years or so
YUM
Oh
you
I mean he has provoked a huge hole on c6
well he seems to know absolutely exactly
what to do
[Music]
that doesn't it's not a good nick good
news if you play the Kings Indian just
like occasionally like for fun yen in a
blitz game it can be tricky because the
opening is just so confrontational if
you make a mistake you sometimes just
get in I elated and this could be one of
those cases
96
how do I ever
it is all in the rest
you
you hear the church bells ringing in the
background
maybe you do but maybe the microphone is
not capturing this it sound pretty good
microphone it's recording this
early on Christmas Eve
you
so at least white is taking a moment now
so 96 I go Queen to f8 that was my plan
not being happy about it
yeah I mean there were many moose I'm
not sure that if this is good I am
didn't really look at this one
so where do we put this to have six
see five I'm not sure c5 is just
probably not good
you
a move that I have some healthy respect
[Music]
office-like h4 if i go back like h4 but
exactly am i doing them
hey guy hey god it doesn't matter have
to make a move it split
you
you
so this is at least attacking the g4
pawn
what
I'm not sure that it's really hanging
because Nagi for Bishop takes Queen
takes at the entity six is possibly also
why to tender
maybe I can just go a 6x5 him and kick
kick this night back
don't quite know what to do against age
form
okay so he just grabs material move that
I didn't consider actually at all
it's rooks e7 a thing maybe
now this is hanging so I have to make
the effort to make a move rook c7
you
boxes seven don't know
if this is
[Music]
yeah
don't really have a good reply to that
I have all kinds of
incorrect sacrifices
you
this is one of them one of the incorrect
sacrifices
I don't know what to do kind of
sacrifice not hey look at the great
thing that I can do here it just doesn't
work
she takes a six looks completely fine
now or this one
don't really want to take it
yeah
I only have a look and and apiece on all
the material for the Queen I mean
Bishop d3 j5 is probably an absolute
disaster we would hear what happens
you
want to do that
but I didn't see an alternative
you
now that was a real opening disaster the
position was just too bad this is what
what can what definitely can happen if
you play a sharp opening like the Kings
Indian and you meet somebody who has
learned his stuff you're just getting
wiped out
and like I'm not an expert and this is
the thing yeah of course I can resign
so I really must basically toast out of
the opening I mean I think this still
should be the way to play this but I'm
not really I don't know I don't know for
sure
this is what this is how it always was
played back in the day and I know that
this is the thing but I'm not sure how
good that is
so g4 took it
and that already looked pretty awful
[Music]
engine wants to play a six probably this
is already not good
rook c4 is by far the strongest move
here
not a move that I expected
yeah
success is given as stronger even
when it felt enough I'd like enough age
for what I expected was good but white
is just better here okay here I actually
could have taken and played this which
seems to be okay
and that was my only opportunity but at
the time I already was so much down on
the clock
and he I just have no reply so it was a
pretty pretty bad game but um it's
something that definitely can happen if
you play such a sharp opening and you
have no clue really why your clue is you
know oh it then somebody with the
specialist knowledge sometimes can wipe
you out in this case I mean header and
had a chance to do something with at the
time I was so much behind on the clock
that I simply couldn't couldn't figure
it out
yeah so let's play
something out of them
it's simple D for repertoire
you
he gave me the bishop a rain
[Music]
Castle first I do a play is v92 whale
but remember I think I can't castle
first
my experience with those kind of porn
grabs once White has the bishop pair he
on
and this one M is that you always have
good compensation you don't relate and
need to young nail every single move
perfectly it's always going to be pretty
strong compensation
it's of course good know the details but
it's not a ttle if you if you forget
them
I'm okay now how do we do this 92
or more conservatively
I can always do this first
yeah let's do it the conservative way I
think after coming Quincy 292 I will get
the pawn back with a very nice position
you could have played in gambit style a
Quincy to work on latitude just allow
him to take but
and I was too quick 92 was maybe
stronger
[Music]
the night definitely wants to take on c4
and it's not completely clear that the
queen is good there I was just I think
maybe Mona
after the the game before where I was in
this time chime trouble I'm yeah it's
mood of let's play quickly
you
you
okay
it's not going to take on g3a this
doesn't work hmm
in fact you wonder what his ideas with
Quincy seven because if you go back to
Eastern when I play reform with Bishop
f4 coming
this looks absolutely dreadful
you
yeah yeah also
the rook
what about the rook
I can take here first and then take the
walk
yeah fianchetto Bishop Bishop is quite
strong
sometimes so strong that it wins a fool
not today sir funny name
said some some quote
No
came interesting variation
of the nameless variations in chess
eighty-three Bishop b5
this is all out of mime
I'd like Magnus repertoire
it's really helpful if you write such a
thing you know it somewhat I mean I
don't know every single line I think
that I analyzed and and ultimately put
in the course on chasuble but it's close
and
it's just
[Music]
we writing about an opening is the
ultimate way of learning it this is also
why I always recommend if you if you
learn such an opening like doesn't
matter if it is one of my books or
opening courses or somebody else's I
always recommend you yea put in a little
bit a little bit of work on your own and
trying to figure out some stuff yourself
because there is much much more
effective in learning then simply
consuming something just think about
positions that form the end of the
analysis where there's some kind of
assessment like white is better black is
better whatever and try to find out
yourself why this is the case if you
don't understand it or simply add some
moves and then modern analysis tools are
so good and helpful that you will be
able to sometimes find really
interesting new ideas now how do I do
this I can take on deform and then at
the end I Knight f5 his pawn structure
is kind of kind of um kind of weak
now in f5 is also not a bad idea
I'm going for them simple approach
you
Knight to h4 Queen f6 this kind of thing
[Music]
you
now No
hmm now what
not sure what's best here maybe Queen to
h4
as this comes with a good tempo
yeah he actually thought that Miss
placing the rook would be quite good
but maybe rupee four is not such a bad
thing for him to play
you
[Music]
you
yeah let's have a look at the d5 pawn
I'm not so happy with how I played this
not not certain
[Music]
anything substantial
you
okay
you
that I didn't see at all
you
hmm this is a temple
I'd never wanted to take on d5 because
that would also um make his Bishop a
little bit stronger
you
yeah this is actually move that I felt
it's not so bad anyway
taking away if for allowing king of
seven
you
just not so clear where he is going with
us with the night air with the bishop to
have a night
Bishop d3 I can actually quantify the
Vermont s Bishop c4 can be answered with
the capture
so he's going for this 95 Bishop c4
whoopsie for Brooke 65 yeah that might
be not so bad for what
I don't want that that's not enough
Knight CH is not really
the charade mostly though
you
I have an idea with this
you
maybe he can take and check me huh
is six check
I did not I did not pay attention to
this possibility at all
very unnecessary
you
yeah that was extremely unnecessary I
had a position where I was strategically
a lot better like almost winning and I
basically outplayed myself
you
I didn't see this movie at all
right then he can just promote our that
was terrible I mean white was completely
outplayed like this position is
strategically are more or less and more
or less winning from black
that is a shame I mean I really should
win such a game if white is playing such
a terrible game you should just win
and Joan yeah also also here this is
something that you I mean you might not
be able to win but you can absolutely
never lose the position and okay I mean
I essentially just kept everything and
this is still I mean here this is just
better food like quite clearly but I
overlooked this I did d6 I just didn't
see two six at the right time if I play
this first and then a five it continues
to be terrible deservedly so I mean what
made so many strategic mistakes but I
just blundered this and this is all of a
sudden completely turning around
I can go to f6 though this is something
that I did not really appreciate I
thought but this is still okay
not okay
you
96 wins I am such an idiot
so easy this is easy stuff ah oh come on
that was a really bad game not in good
shape
were not good at all it was kind of a
basically a gift this this whole game
was a gift that I just have to take and
I didn't do it
you
[Music]
okay then after just make the rock
suffer
and there's no relation between the rock
and earlier opponent but what the heck
yeah just at night 85
it's probably playable
it's probably playable but it's not
really looking good
so I'm just going to play this in a lazy
chest fashion
before
this is some very
very long known kind of structure
in the Kings Indian win only complex but
one key point is that compared to some
other versions of that overnight on d2
and this makes currency for a lot easier
we'll see how leg intends to ever get
denied to a good position maybe him will
never manage and that happens quite
often actually the night stays offside
till the end of the game because you're
kind of in a bad circuit you can go to
b7 at some point then to d8 and then you
kind of wonder what's next so once you
put the knight on a5 you more or less
have to find some kind of tactical idea
on the queenside if you don't find any
your position just usually sucks
let's see what The Rock is doing
nothing much
just stopping any Bishop g4 94 whatnot
yeah this is all nice and good but
doesn't lead to anything
the movie 5 is now on the agenda
if he plays rook b8 which is probably
his idea he cannot even take this pawn
this Bishop takes e5 would win the
exchange
so we'll see what happens
sometimes playing 'if I've black is a is
a reasonable idea
you normally respond by taking on
persona and then playing a five
see what the rock is doing EP just
ignores everything
and this I find hard to believe that
this should be a good position okay I
can take on d6 which is probably pretty
strong or okay let's let's play quickly
I played the whole game quickly and
let's continue in this fashion
it is often possible to just think for a
long time and then you recognize okay
everything was good for you like
everything and then you see are sitting
there and you have no time and then it
didn't really matter how good your
position was this whatever looks really
questionable like
Knight g5 threatens Knight f7 checkmate
a bishop at five though
ruk e 7 is also strong move probably
thank you ship f5 might be a move
against us
you can also just take I mean come on
let's do this and not make it too
complicated
I am so Quincy 3 I thought
you
should be should be something
threatening ninety-eight now
is the immediate idea
attacking the Queen end the night with
mate
it's already pretty pretty strong
and his reaction is no reaction isn't 98
just winning why not
what is what am I missing I mean I
missed lots of stuff in the games before
this is why I'm a little bit skeptical
of my own ability there but 98 is just
winning right win g7 made
yeah even Dwayne Johnson cannot save
this huh does the rock play chess maybe
he does okay so um I think after you
five the position is completely over
right here plus three close to plus free
this so we'll set up is actually not
good I mean here you you don't have any
reason to account a play for black and I
mean there's a little incentive to do
this really it has little upside okay so
let's go for one or more games playing
Nansen with black let's at least across
the two 550 mark not getting much higher
than the high 2500 so I'm always
concealing points
and Ostler costly games
unsurprisingly something that
have analyzed for
I like Magnus one of his trademark
variations
fifty-five it's not exactly something I
expected
what is the bishop doing on d5
not going to take on six
right looks very strange
you
and he's got a five somehow
and I just wondered if I can do
something really good against it
didn't see
you can play night before here if you
want
I don't know I I always have this
problem that I tend to be too ambitious
if I feel like the bishop d5 is just
honestly a silly move it doesn't make
much sense but it is not so bad that
white should lose or anything but and I
tend to be too ambitious if I think okay
this guy played a strange move now I
should try to be better and whatever and
this is sometimes just a little bit too
much like hey I have absolutely no
problem quite clearly but it's not yeah
it's what he did it's not so bad
that I should be much better anything
and in fact maybe it isn't bad at all
it's just yeah somewhat unconventional
way to play that it's probably not the
best but not terrible either sometimes
in blitz that can be an issue
yeah you take time using the hey this is
strange can I not get an advantage and
then all of a sudden you notice that
you are down on time
is he going form I know what he's doing
here you know I mean I I think I can
never be
as him
question is can I do anything
take
yeah it's just equal right
difficult to not take
the long run
yeah pawn takes is kind of normal
Jim
I just think this looks pretty equal
you
anything that I could do here probably
not young King King could defend e6 and
then I could try to try to send him a
queen on some some mission like here but
yeah it's not not going to be dangerous
I think for white
and g5 I think I have Queen h3 this is
not going to be anything special
oops I can pre move the reCAPTCHA on b6
b5 Queen h3 I mean it's probably
just equal anyway
you
now I could treat
is notoriously difficult to assess
I don't really want to risk
den surely bad ending this is just going
to be okay and in fact
fact
you know
no but I can put the Queen onto g5
Queen g5 is that maybe something
that I could try to play for win maybe
the capture could be problematic again
an outside person
well the king has to move
we have three
yeah but not not quite certain what what
I'm doing them
as I cannot move the Queen to d2 or
anything then that's Queen g7
I think this I can definitely a ski
cottage for them
no no absolutely impossible to do
anything
hmm interesting so h2 yeah come on let's
take h2
you
whenever six but
I should always be able to make a draw
simply by checking
his king is also wide open
now some are still it is it's gotten
quite interesting
on that very Jewish position
it might still be very Jewish
but um
game continues you can always just draw
with the perpetual
I don't think I had a perpetual
have to be a little bit alert that I'm
not stumbling into some kind of
we trade that that loses
you know it's going to be real
No yeah probably nothing ever happened
in this game okay so one more one more
game for the session let's get going
Sergio sixteen I am it sounds like a
plan I am at sixteen
so whenever
/ Nick off
you
yeah one of them absolute main lines
this is what I recommend in the course
one of many possible variations
93
just 93
really it's early
don't play this so earlier what just
giving me giving me a couple of 10 B
okay
you
and this is a bit bit weird everything
when I can go here
I cannot take because of Queen h5 but
this could be an idea if he goes g4 now
I can go Bishop f4 and then I basically
have a known kind of position or at
least structure where he has played the
knight back and forth for no apparent
reason
huh back again
couple of things that I could try can go
before him
about it
you
yeah I'm not certain I mean
define with many many things one
important point is that he just cannot
castle in vineyard Lee
this h4 is just hanging
can be
just gave me that square
maybe 92 again to trade trade even more
as I said normally you just put the
knight the bishop on 2f form in this
kind of scenario
taking only three is also possible a
team
[Music]
mm-hm
you
it's a bit unusual this whole
configuration
you
click on g5
possible team
you
yeah I wasn't afraid of that that would
be very surprised if this is anything
or for white
how do we go about this the Queen
ship takes h7s
first thing we have to look at this but
it's the queen going to f6 or I can also
lay Queen b6
you
yeah c'mon I'm a bit bit down on time
whites main idea to win this game is
probably to win on time because
I'm just thinking about easy moves for
too long
[Music]
probably both moves are good so play one
of them
the main issue with White's position is
the absolute lack of coordination
yeah I thought rookie 2 was a pretty
substantial threat but he disagrees or
just didn't see this
hmm
yeah but I can probably
stop this for the moment
so we have a cookie too
[Music]
possible
and no it's not as strong as it was
before actually
come on I'm probably bad
[Music]
problem
doing a really bad job of punishing this
stuff what he's doing
[Music]
really bad yeah here's Queen f4 yes his
stuff
not sure how I'm going to stop it
f 6
not exactly what I wanted
and playing a really bad session I mean
I'm not punishing nonsensical play and
this is sorry I mean I'm always very
frank about this but why just it it was
pretty much nonsensical I should simply
punish it and I didn't manage
position might not be that terrible but
I have 9 seconds
you
rook h3 III something like that is
probably a big problem
you
I don't see how I can improve the
the thing
can I make some headway in the night is
always kind of dependent on the Queen
until
piling up on that pond we'll probably
take it
I have Quincy wonder if he takes it now
bit of a problem Queen h4 is made made
threat
maybe it's not easily winning at least
an F 12 seconds
you
you
probably silly
you
it's not so handle easy to handle this
position for white I mean I just haven't
got nine seconds
but I'm
catching on
we need five Queen f4 stop
you
yeah so finally crumbled
yeah I'm still very disappointed that
I'm not just punishing this stuff you
cannot play like this with g4 and
someone that's just not a good way to
play and that didn't really prove it at
all
so Bishop f4 I mean the computer is
giving me an advantage but I took very
long and it didn't really feel well so
this this rookie age king of one and now
now man I just need a little bit more
precision probably Queen f6 seemed to be
better I am yeah the Queen f6 you know
what I only later realized but this is
not so easy a thing to do in a blitz
game I'm always stuck to this Knight and
it's really difficult for me to use the
Queen actively once I mean it just
always has to cover the night and that
was difficult I mean the computer still
says I'm winning but it was difficult to
play okay now it goes down I mean it's
this is a thing I mean this is depth to
any form that that is something where
the evaluation could change drastically
if it goes deeper but Queen f6 I kind of
didn't know what to do
it's probably just stronger because the
Queen is just more active here and the
idea is always f3 which cuts the what
yeah and it's very difficult for wider
defenders it seems that actually Queen
d7 is best but this I didn't consider
something that you maybe do if you have
more time
I only looked at moves that covered to
the night because I didn't want Bishop
h7 yeah and here I'm just losing losing
the threat alone but f3 maybe right I
don't know h6 and him yeah I mean this
is a move that I wanted to play with the
thing is I don't think I'm threatening
much he cannot take it and I'm on this
but I'm not actually threatening to move
the knight because then he takes on e2
computer finds Quincy one has the only
defense which is funny I didn't see the
move but I'd see the point yeah here or
sacrifice here for counter-attack so it
seems g6 was actually right and I'm
still winning this but now rookie two
was kind of panic mode here because the
time was so low getting low and I don't
have to do this I can play f6 or
something and still win and this just
doesn't work
I think rook h3 is really atrium the
engine gives us is killing me
I think what he did just trying to take
on it - it's not it's just not enough
look f 2 then F 4 and and and T I'm fine
I mean I kind of avoiding the the
immediate draw was maybe in the slightly
tilted but I don't think I'm risking
much here because his king is so open
when I went here and the engine confirms
that this is still a draw I can always
give checks to end the game
yeah Quincy - was now killing me okay I
shouldn't go there as age seven is
hanging
and this is this is difficult to defend
and and in fact already lost and f5 is
winning yeah I just felt like I should
like ended it here I should just fire
now
and I expected kingi to and ng4 and this
in such an open if you open this up the
one who checks first is usually winning
I didn't calculate this really I just
felt okay that should do the trick
yeah so here there's a way for example
to win the Queen
maybe there's something better with you
win the Queen yeah not such a great
session I hope you enjoyed it anyway
thanks for watching